native aldi three and one three zero for
the era
and nate's been outstanding ten
strikeouts last time out an 11-3 victory
over the white sox that tied a career
high hanukkah to get in here for seattle
swing here and pop it up
a little fight in the sun here comes
gonzalez and marwan there to make the
play he's back in the lineup after
having last night off that'll bring up
second baseman ty francis
this time france-based hit into the
corner down near the pesky pole right
rolling around down there marwin
gonzalez here's the throw to second
not in time a one out doubled by ty
france his sixth double of the season
payoff to seeger
[Music]
hit it hard base hit past the diving
arroyo gonzalez will
throw home ty france scores standing up
one-nothing mariners there's taylor
tremell had last night off
so tremel is aboard
got hit on a back foot there in that 2-2
pitch all loaded up for luis torrens the
catcher
ground ball right to short the shovel in
time and he limits the damage one run in
for seattle and they'll be facing chris
flexon as we mentioned
great job last time out this will be his
fourth start of the season he's got the
one-on-one record 3.38 era it's arroyo
[Applause]
ty france
plays in the field
and throws out arroyo there's jd
martinez fifth in batting
in the american league that's a
wonderful play yet again by the gold
club first baseman evan white we go to
inning number two one-nothing mariners
there's him hagerty switch hitter
there you go slaps it the other way base
hit good start to the second henniger
flied to right it was hit very hard in
the first inning
trying to hold up could not contain
himself and he strikes out
first one today for native aldi two
outrunners scoring position for ty
france
after the first pitch slow roller might
have something he does everybody's safe
base hit two for two day for ty france
now you bring up kyle seeger
high fly ball
towards the triangle going back for dugo
can't get it
hagerty scores
[Applause]
france he comes around to score checking
in again with rbi's kyle seeger
three-nothing mariners they got hot real
quick after a no for 20. didn't he well
we talked about it dave a second ago
they're going to have to change that
graphic again another hit with a runner
and scoring position for kyle seeger
this one deep into the triangle
verdugo given chase it looked like the
ball just continued to carry battling
the sun just a little bit but kyle hits
this ball about 410 feet
that gets away
here comes seeger he gets down he scores
four nothing mariners here in the second
inning good starter
here with bogarts to the plate bogart's
devers and gonzales
rips that one headed for the wall that
gets there quickly
hagerty
will hold them to a base hit a fenway
single for xander bogarts
here's marwin gonzalez curveball swing
and a foul tip into the glove but
terence hangs down to it for strike
three and flexon has his first strike
out of the ball game don't back banning
269 no home runs and four runs batted in
ground ball seeger
seems to be universal oh yeah
as seeger throws out bobby dahlback who
was seattle born torrance 0 for one he's
hit into a fielder's choice four-nothing
seattle 0-2 and got him struck him out
he gets him in order francie cordero a
left fielder
good pitch
strikes out cordero second k
for chris flex here's veteran journeyman
catcher
kevin flowecky
straight three call quick work nice job
by flexing first strikeout looking third
for the game top of the order here's
arroyo swinging at a miss go get him big
fella strikes out the side for the last
five and he's got a four-nothing lead
top of the order hannigan next nobody on
base
hammered at third devers with the
backhand
another good inning for a baldy they go
in order we'll check on alex madugo when
we come back
and 1-1
he strokes that one and it's going to be
underneath haggard he couldn't make the
play
and verdugo has got himself a knock here
to begin the inning and the red sox have
runners on it first and second with
nobody out for xander bogarts on one
pitch
didn't get it all hardly at all here's
hagerty coming in
right off the label here's debra's third
baseman
jp will make it a double play right here
a little hip check on that ground ball
by flex it double play very timely
four-nothing mariners cigar rbi single
to run triple put a good swing on this
into the triangle look at it carry on
this baby off the wall
boy that would be two home runs here
at t-mobile park
so he just needs a home run for the
cycle taylor tremell rbi opportunity for
him
crazy hop benefits the mariners run
scores five nothing seattle bogarts
can't make the play you don't see this
very often but this ball hits right
where the grass meets the dirt
that was a nasty kicks forward
he did did a good job just to get a
glove on it given the kick yeah there's
nothing you can really do on that
five-zip seattle
swinging a pop-up
[Music]
arroyo says he has it
on the dirt he's got it but they grab
another run and on top five nothing here
is first baseman bobby dalback the
wind-up and the one-two again fastball
strike three called he gets dull back
looking and that is strikeout number
five for chris flexon here's francie
cordero flexing ready
the o2 and a swing and a miss at a
fastball for strike three and that'll
end the inning six strikeouts
for chris flexon what an afternoon here
at fenway kevin ploweke leads off the
catcher
and he gets plowed wiki again at
strikeout number seven and three
consecutive case alex verdugo still in
there we'll step in he's one for two 1-0
swung on sharply hit but right into the
shift backing up his france he's in the
grass now as he makes the play throws to
first in time to get the outs a one two
three inning flexson continues to roll
he's gone through six and he's blank
boston now he has to manage through a
thorny thicket here with bogarts
standing in is one for two
ground ball turn it there's one
rackham nicely done again by chris
flexing here's raffi now pitch swinging
a high fly left center field hit deep
back by the wall and it is off the top
of the wall rafi on his way to second a
high towering drive that was about two
feet from going out well the double play
certainly hurt raffy with the wall ball
marwin gonzalez is struck out grounded
out
he's going to score easily and the red
sox finally do get that run up there
marwin gonzalez an rbi single see if he
can get bobby dahl back
ground ball
jp
force out flex it seven strong innings
outstanding in boston 5-1 mariners sam
hagerty turn around about right-handed
3-2
sam
big fly
up against it on to the green monster a
home run for sam hagerty batting
right-handed off a taylor gets a
fastball middle in and up and i'll tell
you what he turns on it finds the barrel
406 feet over that monster sam hagerty
checking in with his second home run and
the mariner lead now is 6-1 in the
eighth inning one out two on 6-1
mariners in the ninth 1-1 evan white
broken bat
luper drops in
that'll get one run in
ramirez lead goes to 7-1 rbi for evan
white his sixth certainly a big
opportunity for sam hagerty who's coming
up
and a nice play by don back he's safe
great hustle as always by sam hagerty
picks up another run 8-1 mariners valdez
okey-doken over there and it cost him i
don't think he
he realized how quickly hags was getting
down the line
and that is very close i think sam does
beat it though yeah he does
two down
in the red sox ninth evers will be next
high fly ball that one headed toward the
wall
that caught the monster again verdugo
coming in to score
and they trade places an rbi double to
make it eight to two there's more win
gonzalez rbi single seventh inning
ground ball evan white's got it and that
is your ball game mariners win it 8-2
take game three of the series and lead
this series two games to one really good
stuff